Katy Perry is still talking taylor swift
kendrick lamar gives one fan a
life-changing gift + ryan gosling gets
Harry Styles heart rate pumping well
that confirms it then Harry is a human I
press this is the daily Jenny
I'm Jenny direct oh and it is Wednesday
which means coming up I've got a little
hunt a treat for you
hint it involves a 9 year old with a set
of golden pipes let me tell you but
first just when you thought we heard the
last of Katy Perry and Taylor Swift's
feud someone has asked her about it once
again as she obliges this time it was on
Australia Today Show where Katy insists
she's ready to let it go I love her I
always have and we've had our
differences but I just continue to say
god bless her on her journey less talky
more tsingy god bless her on her journey
is the new I very much like to be
excluded from this narrative which by
the way it's the one-year anniversary of
that old beef that's right a year ago
Kim Kardashian released those snapchats
of Taylor and Kanye's now notorious
phone call about his song famous which
prompted Taylor to fire back to explain
she never approved the song and that she
quote would very much like to be
excluded from this narrative one that I
have never asked to be part of since
2009 and I would very much like a new
album from you Taylor one that addresses
this nonsense but also brings the same
fire of 1989 take things alright don't
you miss the days when she was running
around with Harry Styles while Taylor's
ex is busy these days becoming a star of
the screen his new world war ii drama
Dunkirk is out on Friday and while the
film is getting some early Oscar buzz
there's something or I should say
someone that's got Harry's blood pumping
as BBC host Nick Grimshaw armed with a
heart rate monitor found out how does
this image make you feel
it's Ryan Gosling from The Notebook
looking very handsome mm-hmm a good fan
grasing heart rates rising to a tray yep
he's great 18 no it's not don't fight it
Harry
it's Ryan Gosling and because we care of
course we at et had to ask Harry about
the stunt at last night's Dunkirk
premiere in New York City no I think you
get that runs up jumping so handsome
well Harry got fans hearts pumping on
the red carpet and apparently he's got a
pair of famous admirers in the form of
Kathie Lee and Hoda you can watch them
fangirl over the 23 year olds
tonight on ici meanwhile Kendrick Lamar
just gave one of his diehard fans a new
set of wheels
but not just any fan Jennifer Phillips
was in a terrible car accident nearly a
decade ago she suffered a spinal injury
which left her a quadriplegic in April
she started a GoFundMe campaign to raise
money for a new modified van since hers
was left in pretty bad shape well
Kendrick took notice and helped pay for
the new van prepare yourself because her
mom's reaction will bring you to tears
did you tell her now you know that means
wait
on Friday Jennifer got the chance to
meet the rapper during his tour stop in
Dallas Texas Kendrick even surprised her
with a sign tour jacket with a
personalized message for all the years
of inspiring me the least I can do is
make sure you're comfortable driving in
the city a gift for me to you and that
ladies and gentlemen is how you stayed
humble speaking of Drake was reminded of
his humble beginnings the singer took to
Instagram on Monday to share a hilarious
royalty check from his Degrassi days to
the tune of $8.25 well it's a good thing
Drake's music career took off moving on
to one young singer who is on the brink
of superstardom herself
nine-year-old Angelica Hill you'll
remember her as the adorable America's
Got Talent contestant who told the
judges she wants to be the next Whitney
Houston well last night she hit the
stage too while the judges and guest
judge Chris Hardwick all over again
[Music]
[Applause]
daddy's one player
[Applause]
Wow that girl is on fire and that is how
I fall down a rabbit hole of these
auditions needless to say she nailed it
and not only did she make it through the
first night of the judge cuts round she
headed straight to the live show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I the only one who the sucker for
these shows please let me know okay you
guys I have to run out of here and catch
a train to San Diego because starting
tomorrow we are coming to you live from
Comic Con I'll be there all weekend
bringing you the latest from the
convention so hit subscribe so I can
bring you along and be sure to keep
up-to-date over at ET online.com so I'll
see you guys small gotta go so excited